je pense que les problèmes
alors s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
merci
ces
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
zach je vais aller me rapprocher
je veux dire tu peux tu peux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements  ]
euh
[Musique]
ce que
vous avez un bouclier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aussi sûr que  vous pouvez
oh
up
[Applaudissements]
oh
avec votre cœur
[Applaudissements]
allons-y
opposition
[Applaudissements]
bien
oh
[Applaudissements]
dont les vies sont oh tous ici pour aujourd'hui
[  Applaudissements]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vit
[ __ ]
oh
[ __ ] de merde
je ne peux pas attendre que vous le sentiez en
vous
et que vous commenciez une chance j'ai besoin de vous pour
continuer les vies noires comptent
quand je sors de cette baise, j'ai besoin que vous continuiez tous
bien
[Applaudissements] la
vie compte continue
[Applaudissements]
[ __ ]
est
[Applaudissements]
papplaudissements]
[Musique]
boucliers
[Applaudissements]
euh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
euh
[Musique]
donc
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant
[Musique  ]
tu dois revenir en arrière comme
ça tu peux te tenir derrière moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
super
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
euh
oh
[Applaudissements] d'
accord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Applaudissements] d'
abord
[Applaudissements]
oh
euh
[Applaudissements]
ici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi
[Musique]
étranger
[Musique  ]
euh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
euh numéro quatre en fait
[Applaudissements]
elle est de notre côté depuis le jour du 21.
depuis le premier jour
[Applaudissements] tout à l'heure
c'est gentil  de fou
[Applaudissements]
je suppose que  e fed est vraiment de la musique
cette partie que la caméra vient de
brancher juste ici
[Applaudissements]
étranger
prenons ce [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce soir
[Applaudissements]
je vais chercher mes tables  en ce moment
moi
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
euh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est le
nom est ouais et le nom de son fils est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
patrick
[Musique] en
fait ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
euh
aaron campbell dit son nom
par son nom
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai il y a une autre jeune femme
que la police de portland a tuée
en 2002 son nom est kendra james
dit son nom
un autre il avait 17 ans  garçon d'un an
hé
[Applaudissements]
il y en a deux en particulier
son nom était jason washington a vu son
nom
[Applaudissements]
une autre femme qui a été tuée ici tout
récemment juste ici en 2020
elle était à la maison dans un arbre dans un parc ici à
portland
elle a été pendue ici  dans un arbre et la
police a
appelé au suicide une
femme noire  pendu à un arbre dans un parc
ici,
ils ont refusé d'ouvrir son dossier, ils ont
refusé de le traiter comme un crime haineux,
son nom allait tt
[Applaudissements]
maintenant
[Musique]
comprendre une chose que nous,
les Noirs, comprenons
et comme le fait que vous êtes tous ici
pour nous car les vies noires comptent,
mais une chose que nous voulons savoir ne rentrez pas
chez vous,
ils en ont assez des gens qui viennent ici
et disent que les vies noires comptent et quand
ils les voient dans la rue,
ils ont confiance  leur pire ou leur porte verrouillée
ou ils entrent dans l'autre rue
et vous êtes là
pour nous et vous croyez que les vies noires
comptent ne laissez pas cette merde
s'arrêter ici c'est tout et
toute la journée pour nous, nous ne pouvons pas enlever notre peau
et  se promener et être d'accord, comprendre que
nous avons
[Applaudissements]
parce que
comme si nous avions une sorte de [ __ ] de
mécontentement parce que les
[ __ ] ne veulent pas être autour de nous
parce que nous sommes des
[ __ ] de noirs je comprends que
vous êtes tous heureux [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc si vous  voulez nous soutenir, vous faites savoir aux
étrangers
[Applaudissements]
arrêtez-vous ici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] d'
accord d'accord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Applaudissements  ]
vous devez tous être
[Applaudissements]
allons-y
[Applaudissements
] c'est un mouvement
des bénédictions infinies sur tout le monde ici
j'espère que l'amour et les bénédictions sur vous tous
marquent les sept personnes d'
accord en ce moment nous essayons de faire
quelque chose de si grand  en ce moment
je vérifie cette merde
[Applaudissements
] c'est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] d'
accord
[Applaudissements]
c'est
ne dénigrez pas les autres
oh
[Applaudissements]
c'est
i  je ne suis pas ici pour la réforme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais sinon parlez aussi
je veux que vous sachiez que la flamme de la
liberté
qui a été pervertie est en
chacun de ceux qui sont en
train de bouger [Applaudissements] maintenant
Ne laissez plus cette flamme de la liberté
être utilisée contre nous, nous sommes le
peuple en ce moment
et nous sommes le château
que nous sommes ici c'est ce qu'est l'
Amérique juste
ici c'est comme dans l'ensemble
[Musique]
toutes les couleurs différentes se réunissent
parce que nous sommes
fatigués
c'est
[Musique]
continuez à parler des messages
allez
oui
sais ce qui se passe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
j'étais comme
euh
[Applaudissements]
oh
mais vous vous souvenez tous que Ted Wheeler doit y
aller aussi parce que merde
si c'est connecté
[Applaudissements]
[Applaudissements  ]
hé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
étranger
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas de bon dieu
que voulons-nous
[Applaudissements]
ça va
je vais
bien
[Musique]
euh
oh
nous te sommes reconnaissants  'tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais je veux que vous sachiez que cela a été lancé par
la
boule noire des mamans qui se sentent ici
se sont fait tirer dessus ont reçu des gaz lacrymogènes
[Applaudissements]
par la police ici pour
nous et personne  a dit un mot
je veux que vous en parliez maintenant
il y a un procès fédéral à cause du
mur blanc des mamans qui est sorti
et a été gazé une fois
qu'ils ont je sais que maman tu es sortie
ici
et reconnu et parlé de nous remercions
toutes les mamans noires
qui sont venues ici et soutiennent ce
mouvement,
nous voulons que
vous écriviez cela et disiez  regardez, nous avons eu
le mur noir des mamans qui sont sorties et se sont
blessées
sans qu'elles prennent position sans qu'elles se
présentent
comme beaucoup d'entre nous veulent être ici, le
mur blanc des montagnes
n'existerait même pas, alors comprenez que
nous avons  beaucoup de mamans noires ici, nous
avons beaucoup de mamans noires ici
[Applaudissements]
depuis le premier jour, mettant le
pied sur ces trottoirs, je veux que vous le
voyiez tous
parce que je sais souvent ce que la
société voit,
c'est que quand  une personne blanche est blessée des
dommages ont été causés mais ils ne voient pas
l'arrière-plan
lorsqu'une personne noire a été blessée des dommages
ont été causés
ces foules noires
ont fait tout ce qu'elles pouvaient souvent le
système retire le bureau de l'
équation
et que se passe-t-il alors ils nous ont combattus pour
ne pas être là  e
non je ne suis pas un père, je dis juste qu'ils
se sont battus pour
ne pas être là et ont dit que vous êtes tous des
bâtards,
ils n'ont pas votre père mais vous avez
retiré le père de l'équation
de la maison et ensuite nous avons mis le
la pression
sur les mamans noires et ensuite elles viennent
ici
et font ce qu'elles font et se tiennent pour nous
et parlent leur voix et personne ne
chante ou n'en parle mais quand
la maman blanche sort
et se blesse, il y a un gros problème
les vies noires comptent noir  la vie
compte compte
[Applaudissements]
si maman noire ne
m'importait pas je suis un gars noir je ne serais pas là
[Musique]
le reste de ces noirs ne sera pas là
vous leur dites
bien campbell n'a pas de factures
et ils ont besoin de reconnaissance  pas parce
qu'elles sont noires pas parce qu'elles sont mères
mais à cause des deux elles sont une mère noire qui
défend le bon
homme
parce qu'elles sont en colère parce que certaines d'
entre elles n'ont pas de mère noire
certaines d'entre elles n'en ont pas  un père noir et
nous nous fâchons contre eux pour avoir agi et le
cul par colère mais ils n'ont
pas d'autre choix  si vous ne défendez
pas le modèle noir
et ne les aidez pas à soutenir la jeunesse noire,
quelle est la raison pour laquelle vous êtes ici car
les vies noires comptent,
alors arrêtez de mettre les bombes noires à l'
arrière,
amenez-les devant  et dis que
nous te soutenons nous allons te protéger nous allons nous
tenir devant toi quand ils viendront
ils doivent m'atteindre avant qu'ils
n'arrivent [Applaudissements] ne me regarde pas en face dis que je te
soutiens mon frère alors  la police peut être comme
[ __ ] de [ __ ] de [ __ ] de merde
je n'ai pas besoin de ça je n'ai pas besoin de ça j'ai
besoin que tu sois avec moi
parce que 95% du temps vous me voyez tous
je
me tiens toujours devant je suis toujours dehors
ici
et je protégerai autant de personnes que
possible parce que j'en
ai besoin et la bonne chose à faire et
je me soucie de vous tous,
alors quand je suis ici et que vous me
voyez tous, vous savez tous pourquoi je '  Je suis ici
quand nous sommes assis ici et continuons à demander aux gens
pourquoi êtes-vous ici,
regardez autour de vous, c'est pourquoi nous sommes ici
parce que les vies noires comptent
[Applaudissements]
je suis  identifiez-le avant si vous ne défendez pas
quelque chose,
vous tomberez pour tout ce que je représente pour
les vies noires comptent
et je ne tombe pas pour la merde [ __ ] de ça
[Applaudissements]
alors quand vous nous soutenez tous,
soutenez-nous, soutenez-nous pleinement
l'autorité vient à nous
et sache comment tu vas vas-tu
bien tu es cool
laisse-moi voir ce que je peux faire pour t'aider tu
as besoin d'une épaule
quand tu dis que les vies noires comptent c'est
plus que juste venir ici vérifier
prends ton cul en ligne  et j'ai besoin que vous
votiez,
sortez ces connards du bureau et
attendez-les
une justification pour les
bourses [de musique]
voyez, mais si nous avions la liberté d'
organiser les milices seraient tout aussi
bien organisées,
le principal avantage qu'elles ont est qu'elles ont
été comme si j'avais l'impression que leur principal
avantage était qu'elles pouvaient jouer à
travers leurs batailles
parce que  je pense en fait que comme je
regarde toujours cen  la centralisation comme
ça est un problème parce qu'alors votre
réponse est
je suis si heureux tout le monde ici
nous essayons de rendre le monde meilleur je
me sens intelligent à chaque fois que je crache laissez-
moi lever mon masque
juste pour que je puisse rapper comme ça apportons
il revient blanc noir natif
et tout le monde qui est
[Musique]
c'est
et
[Musique]
vous savez déjà pas de chaussures
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
bonjour
est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[  Applaudissements]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hé qu'est-ce que c'est
[ __ ] d'
[ __ ]
[Musique]
je m'en
fous de l'histoire [ __ ]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que nous avons tous été mis à niveau
d'un rassemblement illégal à orion,
c'est comme si le comportement était différent, non,
nous secouons la clôture autant
qu'hier ouais
voyons ce qui se passe  de l'autre
côté de la foule, c'est bon pour vous tous,
restez en sécurité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un coup d'oeil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci pour cela, soyez
toujours prêts parce qu'ils sont sortis et ont
commencé à tourner
même si nous n'avons rien fait
mais amusons-nous si quelqu'un
veut brancher un ipod
[Applaudissements]
c'est une chance d'être une communauté
alors vous écoutez tous cette jeune femme,
elle a besoin d'aide,
nous avons besoin de quelqu'un pour intensifier la
communauté d'accord
[Musique]
communauté
tout ce dont vous avez besoin la frapper
j'achète totalement le temps parce que je  j'ai perdu mon chien juste
ici
rassemblons-nous je pense que cette chanson est
[Musique]
minoritaire comme un jour
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-
ce que ça n'a rien à voir
je sens mauvais
tu as senti ça
[Musique]
non
ça
[Musique]
hein
quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Applaudissements] tant
pis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
tous les jours
j'ai besoin d'être ici
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[  Musique] des
choses folles
je ne sais pas ce qui se passe
ce qui s'est passé si quelqu'un a allumé le
feu quelqu'un étoile  ted pour tirer
ouais mais il y a eu une bagarre ouais probablement à
propos du gars qui a commencé à tirer
qui vas-
tu où vas-tu
attends un instant wow
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est
[Musique]
bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements  ]
[Applaudissements]
un
[Musique]
euh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hey
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
wow
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
euh
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
joyeux anniversaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est
[Musique  ] d'
accord
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que je sais
[M  usic]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui est-ce
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui est la vie
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
wow
[  Applaudissements]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jesus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Musique  ]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hé je veux juste prendre ça très vite
moi aussi
[Applaudissements]
euh
[Musique]
oui
toi